Напруження перед самітом G7 - очікування і протести;
Між радістю і розпачем -
суперечка щодо законів про аборти в Америці;
Нове керівництво, нові шанси? Ліві шукають вихід із кризи.
В ефірі «heute journal» з Гансом Вольфом
та Марієттою Сломкою.
Добрий вечір.
Завтра Олаф Шольц офіційно
відкриє черговий саміт G7,
що проходитиме у мальовничому
містечку поблизу Альп.
Канцлер утримується від завищених очікувань,
наголошуючи, що
у замку Ельмау не будуть перевертати гори.
Найближчими днями чутимемо цю гру слів у новинах
про саміт біля підніжжя гори Цугшпітце дедалі частіше.
Саміти G7 насправді ніколи не були платформою
для ухвалення обов'язкових до виконання рішень.
Історія «Великої сімки» розпочалася в 70-х роках
двадцятого століття,
коли Сполучені штати запропонували проводити
зустрічі «без краваток» для неформальних переговорів.
Так G7 стала майданчиком для обговорення
актуальної ситуації у світі
без протоколів та суворого регламенту.
З плином часу це змінилося.
Від саміту в Ельмау очікують принаймні
демонстрацію єдності та одностайності.
Даніель Понтцен розповість більше.
Одна річ лишається незмінною:
видовищне шоу на посадковій смузі.
Приблизно півгодини тому приземлився
Air Force One з Джо Байденом на борту.
Перед ним вже прибув французький президент;
баварці охоче влаштовують міні-шоу своїх традицій.
Першим до Баварії прибуває
господар заходу Олаф Шольц.
До містечка Ельмау канцлер дістається гелікоптером.
«Ми не перевернемо гори під час цього саміту в горах» -
поетично та відверто повідомив Шольц
у своєму відеозверненні.
Спершу «Велика сімка» була «шісткою».
Одного разу Гельмут Шмідт запросив шість країн зібратися
для обговорення тодішньої нафтової кризи у світі.
Наразі важливо обговорити сучасну ситуацію
в світі та водночас подбати
про зміну клімату, спричинену людьми.
Саме зміна клімату була заздалегідь зазначеною
як головна тема зустрічі,
однак війна в Україні відсунула все на другий план.
Однією з найбільш нагальних проблем є загострення
світової продовольчої кризи.
Зміна клімату залишається на порядку денному,
зокрема вона важлива  й для гостей
зустрічі - Індії та Індонезії.
Хоча головною темою саміту буде
все ж війна в Україні.
Багато країн стверджують, що це
загальноєвропейська війна,
яка спричиняє багато економічних проблем,
яким ми не можемо дати раду миттєво.
Це лише підвищує тиск на народ України,
який схиляють до укладення мирної угоди
на невигідних умовах.
Саме з нагоди саміту Путін оприлюднив
повідомлення, яке в Ельмау
сприйняли як дуже токсичне привітання,
очевидно, такою і була його мета.
У заяві йдеться про
розміщення ядерної зброї у Білорусі.
Крім того, Росія знову активізувала
свій наступ в Україні.
Ще ніколи ситуація у світі не була настільки складною
та невизначеною, про що свідчать
численні протести, які прокотилися
низкою європейських країн.
Замість очікуваних 20 тисяч у Мюнхені зібралося
лише 5 тисяч демонстрантів.
Люди спантеличені, вони не знають, які протести
наразі важливіші, а теми нагальніші -
клімат та соціальна справедливість чи війна в Україні.
На вечір заплановано подальші акції.
Червоний знак миру від Greenpeace та послання до
учасників саміту на гірськолижному трампліні в Гарміші:
«Ви готові до стрибка?»
У такий спосіб ми хочемо сказати, що справді
розраховуємо на наших політиків
та очікуємо від них не лише слів підтримки, а й
рішення про конкретні заходи,
які реально допоможуть владнати цю кризу.
У одному з правил зі стрибків з трампліна зазначено:
«Байдуже, який розгін ти взяв, від багатьох факторів
залежатиме, наскільки далекої цілі ти досягнув».
Те ж саме правило стосується й учасників саміту
в Ельмау. Цього разу, так би мовити, дме зустрічний вітер.
На зв'язку наш кореспондент у США Ельмар Тевесен,
який також знаходиться в Ельмау.
Ельмаре, які очікування президента Байдена від
саміту? Які питання стоять на порядку денному?
Джо Байден чітко описав свої очікування від
саміту ще у Вашингтоні.
Одностайна реакція, одностайне засудження
війни в Україні має перетворитися
на довгострокову організовану співпрацю,
що ґрунтується на спільних завданнях та спільній меті.
Саме такі очікування від зустрічі. Перш за все
йдеться, звісно ж, про ситуацію в Україні.
Зокрема про продовження військової підтримки України,
усі країни-учасниці прагнуть зробити свій внесок.
Також обговорюватимуть план повоєнної
відбудови України, так званий
план Маршалла, запропонований німецьким урядом.
Також Джо Байден прагне завадити Володимиру Путіну
і надалі наживатися на Європі.
За останні місяці, незважаючи або, можливо, навпаки
через санкції Заходу, ціни на нафту шалено зросли.
Таким чином, щомісяця Росія отримує
додаткових 20 мільярдів доларів,
а це на 50% більше, ніж до початку війни в Україні.
Тому президент США прагне встановити верхню
цінову межу і інші країни ймовірно підтримають
його ініціативу. Таким чином російське паливо
продовжуватимуть купувати, але вже за обмеженими цінами.
Країни G7 також сподіваються на підтримку гостей
саміту - Індії, Індонезії та ПАР.
Якщо делегаціям вдасться дійти згоди в
цьому питанні, вони досягнуть єдності
і стосовно спільної боротьби зі змінами клімату.
Йдеться про взаємну двосторонню допомогу:
промислові держави допоможуть країнам,
що розвиваються, та новим індустріальним країнам.
Федеральний уряд запевняє, що учасники переговорів
на правильному шляху.
Відчувається єдність усіх країн-учасниць.
На фінальній пресконференції дізнаємося,
чи виправдалися очікування делегацій від зустрічі.
Дякую, Ельмаре.
Перед від'їздом на саміт президент Байден
лишив свою країну у справжньому розпачі.
Рішення Верховного суду США про заборону абортів
стало несподіванкою і для самого Байдена.
У кількох штатах, очолюваних республіканцями,
було введено сувору заборону на аборти.
Рішення настільки радикальне, що навіть
забороняє аборт за медичними показаннями.
Для американського духовенства рішення стало
ідеологічною перемогою, попередньою перемогою,
оскільки йдеться насправді не лише про аборти.
Анна Файст з репортажем зі США.
Легалізуйте аборти знову!
Усюди!
На жаль, іноді дуже непросто змусити людей прокинутися.
Мені дуже шкода, що все зайшло настільки далеко.
Заклик до пробудження. Скасування рішення,
ухваленого майже 50 років тому.
У 1973 році право на аборт було закріплено
в Державній Конституції США.
Вчора Верховний суд США, в якому консерватори з часів
Трампа  мають більшість, скасував це право.
Майже в половині з 50 штатів набула чинності
заборона на аборти, або жорсткі обмеження.
Це минуле тепер може бути майбутнім
для мільйонів жінок у Сполучених Штатах.
Розалін Джонас завагітніла у 1966 році, у віці 19 років,
її батьки були суворими католиками.
Вона не хотіла мати дитину.
Через знайомих вона отримала номер.
Якийсь чоловік приїхав на машині та забрав мене.
Ми їхали дуже довго до фермерського будинку.
Увійшов чоловік у масці.
Я сподівалася, що це буде лікар, але я не знала.
Він не розмовляв зі мною.
Аборт проводили без анестезії.
67-річна жінка тепер вже бабуся.
Відтоді вона бере участь у дискусії
про права на аборт, яка триває роками.
Про те, що сталося вчора, їй розповіла донька.
Це неначе тебе облили холодною водою.
Як бути зараз?
Ми забезпечимо, щоб всі жінки,
яким потрібен аборт, знайшли спосіб,
як його зробити.
Але яким чином?
Для Розалін, як і для багатьох інших присутніх
наступного дня,
це було єдиним рішенням:
Ми повинні обирати.
Ми повинні обирати політиків, які виступають проти рішення.
І не здаватися.
Це все ще моя країна, і я збираюся її повернути.
Найближчі місяці покажуть,
чи це насправді був тривожний дзвінок.
Більше новин розповість Ганс.
У Норвегії влада підозрює акт ісламістського тероризму
після смертельної стрілянини біля нічного клубу в Осло.
Внаслідок теракту загинули дві людини загинуло,
понад 20 людей було поранено.
Правоохоронцям вдалося затримати ймовірного зловмисника,
це був норвежець з іранським корінням.
Постріли пролунали перед баром, який є популярним
серед представників ЛГБТ-спільноти.
Запланований на сьогодні прайд-парад скасували.
Однак, багато хто вийшов на вулиці,
у знак підтримки прав квір-спільноти.
У Грузії їх десятки тисяч людей вийшли на демонстрацію
щодо вступу їхньої країни до ЄС.
На мітингу в Тбілісі пізно ввечері
вони звинуватили владу,
що та недостатньо зробила для того,
щоб ЄС оголосив Грузію країною-кандидатом.
Президент України Зеленський запевнили протестувальників
у своєму відеозверненні, що його країна допоможе Грузії
на її шляху до Європи.
У Берліні Служба безпеки кримінального розшуку
розслідує фейковий відеодзвінок
імовірного Віталія Кличка.
Невідомий телефонував мерам Європи,
у тому числі Францисці Ґіффай в Берліні,
на екрані він виглядав і розмовляла так само,
як мер Києва,
однак викликав підозру дивними запитаннями.
Очевидно, це було ретельно оброблена відеотрансляція,
так званий «Глибокий фейк».
Незрозуміло, хто за цим стоїть.
У Північній Рейні-Вестфалії CDU і партія «Зелених»
зробили наступний крок до створення спільного уряду.
На обох партійних з'їздах схвалили рішення
про коаліційну угоду.
Це означає, що практично ніщо не перешкоджає
переобранню прем'єр-міністра Вюста
до парламенту у вівторок.
У CDU серед близько 600 делегатів
лише четверо проголосувало проти коаліційної угоди.
У партії «Зелених» 85% підтримало рішення.
Їхня очільниця парламенту Нойбаур
стане суперміністеркою економіки, клімату та енергетики.
Серед пам'ятних моментів триденної федеральної
партійної конференції
партії «Лівих», була поява
прем'єр-міністра Тюрингії Рамелова.
Очевидно, він вважав за потрібне
просвітити своїх однопартійців,
що Володимир Путін не належить до лівих.
У будь-якому випадку, російська загарбницька війна
є ще однією проблемою для лівих
у пошуках спільних позицій
щодо фундаментальних політичних питань.
Ці пошуки тривають дуже довго і не допомогли партії
подолати 5% бар'єр на федеральних виборах.
І тому цей партійний з’їзд знову став кризовою зустріччю.
Детальніше розповість Андреа Маурер.
Вони повинні зараз вивести партію «Лівих» із кризи:
Мартін Шірдеван і Джанін Вісслер.
Особливо Вісслер зі слабким результатом,
57,5% проголосувала за стару, тепер нову очільницю партії.
Минулого року було 84% голосів.
Між ними – поразки на виборах, звинувачення в сексизмі,
відставка лідера її однопартійців.
Протягом останніх кількох тижнів і місяців
виникали ті чи інші суперечки.
Також в останні дні перед з'їздом партії,
тому це була складна ситуація.
Але я скажу наступне: за мене проголосувала більшість.
Новачок на стороні Вісслер:
Мартін Шірдеван,
досі був співголовою фракції в Європарламенті.
Я думаю, що сигнал зрозумілий:
Ми це зрозуміли, як ліві.
Ми повернулися, як ліві.
І це також сигнал, який цей з'їзд партії надсилає
громадянам.
Хоча Вісслер і Шірдеван все ще приймають вітання,
настрої з'їзду дещо похмурі.
Ті, хто постраждав від LinkeMeToo і сексизму,
обурені переобранням Вісслер.
Я обурена тим, що ми обираємо очільниками
нашої нібито феміністської партії людей,
які явно та відкрито захищають злочинців.
Набридло слухати,
як ми говоримо про зміни в суспільстві,
але не зробили їх сьогодні.
Також на партконференції мала місце
боротьба за владу з партійним крилом
довкола Сари Вагенкнехт.
Ні Вісслер, ні Шірдеван не були фаворитами.
Опівдні Вісслер особисто виступає
проти поправок Вагенкнехт та інших,
які хотіли зафіксувати причетність
Заходу до війни в Україні.
Запит на зміну: відхилено.
Однак невдоволення тих, хто хоче більше роздумів,
менше програмного оновлення, мабуть, ще не настало.
Питання в тому, чи дійсно таким чином
ми насправді зможемо представити новий етап.
Надалі, після цього,
для партії може розпочатися справжнє нове життя.
Це питання залишається відкритим.
Чи слідуватимуть невдоволені за новим керівництвом партії,
чи почне партія «Лівих» з чистого аркуша, -
наразі ще не відомо.
А тепер номери лотереї цієї суботи.
Як завжди, всі дані без гарантій: 2 4 21 28 33 43
Суперчисло: 5
Більше виграшних номерів можна знайти на lotto.zdf.de
і в тексті zdf на сторінці 556.
Переходимо до прогнозу погоди.
Завтра на Сході та Південному сході світитиме сонце,
опадів не буде.
В інших регіонах буде хмарно і пройдуть зливи,
місцями сильні грози.
Температура підніметься і становитиме від 22°до 33°.
Найближчими днями очікуються зливи
та сильні грози.
У понеділок на Сході температура становитиме до 35°.
В інших регіонах максимальна температура становитиме
від 22° до 29°.
Це були всі новини на сьогодні, далі рухаємося
до спорту.
О 00:30 буде випуск «heute Xpress».
До побачення.